Ça me fait grand plaisir de lui
reparler.
Paul Caplette, producteur de
céréales, il exploite avec son
frère Pierre, la ferme Bellevue
située à Saint-Robert
dans la région de Sorel-Tracy
en Montérégie.
- Bonsoir. Bienvenue chez nous.
- Le manque d'eau, est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui, c'est un
problème pour vous?
- Disant que c'est un problème
qui est inquiétant. L'an passé,
on a connu notre pire sécheresse
en 40 ans chez nous sur la
ferme. Cette année, on est
pratiquement 15 à 20 mm en
retard sur notre historique de
l'an passé. Ce qui veut dire
qu'on est un peu... on est
encore confiant mais on est
inquiet. La dernière pluie qu'on
nous annonçait de 20 mm, on n'en
a eu seulement cette. Ce qui
fait que ça fait qu'on a eu
juste assez de rosé en attendant
la prochaine qui pourrait avoir
lieu en fin de semaine. On est
sur le respirateur artificiel.
- Pour quelles céréales c'est le
plus dur? Quelle est la céréale
la plus sensible au manque
d'eau?
- Cette année, la plus sensible,
ça va être surtout la céréale de
printemps comme le blé.
Au niveau de notre blés divers
qui avaient un système racinaire
plus important, vous voyez
sûrement ça sur vos images qu'on
a prises tantôt, il avait plein
de potentiel pour une année
record comme on était parti.
Présentement, la plante veut se
reproduire alors s'il manque
d'eau, au lieu de remplir ces 80
grains, elle va décider d'en
remplir 50 ou 60. Tant que le
feuillage va être capable de
rester vert, les deux ou trois
feuilles du haut, on est tout le
temps confiant de dire... en
espérant la prochaine bouffée de
pluie. Comme le maïs...
- Ça vous prend combien de pluie
pour que vous dormiez mieux?
- On rêvait beaucoup aux 25 mm
pour nous aider un peu. On n'en
a eu le tiers. Si on était
capable d'avoir 15 ou 20 mm, ça
nous permettrait de tenir bon
une semaine ou 10 jours. Les
réserves du sol sont vraiment
basses. Il faut en avoir
toujours un peu pour maintenir
l'activité au niveau de la
circulation des plantes pour
qu'elle soit capable de se
nourrir pour ne pas qu'elles
arrêtent de produire.
- Donc il peut y avoir des
pertes si ça ne va pas mieux?
- Comme les champs de maïs, il y
a probablement déjà des pertes.
Chez nous, ce n'est pas un gros
problème. Mais du maïs qui lève
en retard parce qu'on a semé et
que c'était trop sec, il va
lever 70 % des plans. Des plans
qui lèvent sept ou 10 jours en
retard, même s'il pose après la
pluie qui tombe demain, ça va
être trop tard. Il est tellement
petit comparé aux autres qu'il
va faire un plan de maïs qui ne
sera pas produit. Dans ce genre
de culture, il y aura des
pertes.
- Les producteurs maraîchers
doivent arroser. Vous, c'est
trop grand? Quelle différence il
peut y avoir? Est-ce que vous
devriez imaginer une autre façon
d'amener de l'eau dans vos
champs?
- Présentement, c'est sûr qu'en
mode maraîchage, les surfaces
sont moins grandes. Je connais
des maraîchers que leur
approvisionnement en eau est
déjà épuisé. Si on tombe en mode
grande cultures sont des grandes
surfaces, c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'avoir accès à de
l'eau. Notre technique qu'on
améliore au cours des dernières
années, c'est vraiment de ne pas
manipuler le sol pour rien, de
le couvrir le plus possible pour
essayer de garder le plus
possible la réserve d'eau avec
la fonte des neiges.
Systématiquement, pas se faire
voler d'eau par les mauvaises
herbes. Il faut être à point au
niveau des mauvaises herbes, de
les enlever pour ne pas qu'elle
vole d'eau à nos cultures.
Déjà cette année, même avec la
sécheresse qui est pire que l'an
passé, on se trouve mieux
positionner que l'an passé parce
qu'on a changé des choses dans
notre système pour nous aider à
économiser plus lourd.
Mais ça fait quand même qu'au
final... comme quand on se
promène avec un réservoir
d'essence qui nous dit qu'il
nous reste 5 km.
- C'est toujours un plaisir de
vous parler. Je vais retourner
chez vous et on va pouvoir faire
des entrevues un peu plus
proches. Vous avait un discours
intéressant qui avait beaucoup
intéressé nos téléspectateurs
sur le prix du pain. Vous nous
disiez d'arrêter de vouloir
payer moins cher parce qu'il
vous fallait le produire et le
transformer. Sur les pesticides,
vous avez un discours
intéressant aussi. Salut, à
bient